so party if for example I want to know
well what will happen after this what
will the next step down be I could go
through this whole process again and I
could pick my you and I could pick my DV
however what this working tells me is
that after I've done all that I will get
minus now instead of and I actually
haven't once one don't do this that's
that's this number here so I'm trying to
load up on to it and then this is going
to be not the n minus 1 integral but the
N minus 1 minus 1 integral which of
course is n minus 2 it's the next one
down okay so i can of course to
integration by parts all over again but
the whole point of her penetration is I
don't have to I've done that all and
I've established the pattern now I'm
just going to take advantage of it okay
now I'm gonna do one more step here
because you can see what I've got I'm
trying to fall a patent maybe you need
three terms always to establish a
pattern so I'm just going to want all
right so this is the next one down so
what I'm trying to do is like I did here
right it's a I'm getting one lower power
of whatever okay in this case it's one
lower power of log X every single time
so I'm trying to make this will try to
get this closer and closer to this thing
I could evaluate so what's this one
gonna be minus and minus all over to of
would you do wrong and if I say
fantastic okay so I feel like this is
enough I can I've established a pattern
here but what I need to do is go screw
fighter the pattern then eventually I've
done and I haven't it I have a statement
I just evaluate okay don't have to rely
on with rich my parts so therefore dot
dot dot I'm going to skip a whole bunch
of steps and I want to see what happens
at the end of this what all the very
last term's me again I'm looking for
three terms okay now the last term is
going to be I one right it's going to be
I work there is no I 0
okay so therefore watch what happens
yeah you got to be careful okay I'm
going to actually start at I for I want
three more terms I want three more terms
but because the definition for IM
involves an eye n minus 1 then I want
this one to be by one does that make
sense I don't want it to be a zero
because that does it exist if I want
that to me i won then the last one I
write down will be I to so to get three
in total I'll have two three and four
does that make sense ok so here I am
drop your knife or I'm going to use the
recruits relationship so this is minus 4
over 2 I 13 the next one will be minus 3
over 2 of i 2 and then you're going to
have I to which is now I could write
this as minus 1 ok but I'm trying to
establish a pattern here I don't want
things to be simplified out so they
don't look like a pattern I'm going to
leave that like that which I agree is a
little bit morbid but that's okay go
through i won yeah I've almost there I
need to know what I want is I actually
need to because this is the point like I
had here or it's a cool I've been
climbing down this integration ladder
and eventually I get to the bottom wrong
and I step up and I'm like cool I've got
something that I know the value of not
something which has it more integral to
do ok so therefore let's work out what
my one is I one is actually the integral
from naught to one of what X X DX yeah
which again this this is the same
problem that I had before but that's ok
we will deal with this when we
eventually get been up x for x we've
done this before which is one of the
simplest questions either integration by
parts right can we do our you and L DV
can you tell me what too big yeah
shouldn't be
nope it's because it's log X to the
power of M which in this case is one
going through this mmm normal I've
gotten office now I can't use this line
to define I won because it would rely of
an easier which doesn't exist which
doesn't exist you see that so this is
not a recurrence relation anymore this
is an integral with no more further
integrals after does that make sense not
on the recurrence relation anymore I've
left it behind what am I going to choose
u equals x I think my girls might be a
little more duffel yeah over here that's
going to give me 1 over X here that
leaves me X which leads me to x squared
I'm to this looks familiar doesn't it ok
so here I'm going to have this guy from
nought to one ok which again gives us
that same weird problem we can you see
what I mean like all the way down all of
those movies from 0 to 1 they always
evaluate out 20 once you deal with the
limits which I'm kind of glossing over a
little bit ok here I've got the integral
of VDU vdu which is what is it x.x onto
yeah from north to 1 DX are you happy
with that yeah so as I establish we'll
talk about that later and this is the
integral of exon 2 from nought to one
which is yes having the question as well
they didn't actually
oh sorry sorry of course it is yeah
which actually I did bathroom oh yeah
surely just got excellent rolling on
this particular question very similar
like you think I'll have a look at it I
hope it have a good night i'll actually
just written down i don't know if you
got it okay so we're actually probably
integrating now that's great so now
evaluating it at the top and bottom
boundaries i'm going to get minus 1 over
4 and 0 which is minus 1 over 4 okay now
now where is this going to go i now have
all of these steps of the ladder here
now i will just give a bit of a shout
out to mathematical induction which is
very similar to this when we get to it
you'll see it's all your you stab which
this pattern and you get there it's very
an integer sort of question right